here's some examples that aren't
opposite raised and then we'll talk
about what opposite rays are so let's
jump right into this video letter a here
you can see array is basically like a
ray of sunshine it starts at the Sun
okay for example and it goes outward
just in one direction so you can see
here Raabe it's starting at Point a this
is called the end point but in reality
you can think of it as the starting
point okay but it's called the end point
and it goes towards B and it keeps going
in this direction so we have it written
as Ray a B and here we have Ray CD now
notice when you write the array you
always draw the arrow going to the right
okay and you can see it's starting at
Point C which is right here heading
towards a D and it keeps going in that
direction okay but when you look at
these rays these are technically not
opposite rays okay and the reason
they're not a purse it raises because to
be opposite Ray's you have to start at
the same end point and go 180 degrees
opposite so for letter B here you might
think okay what about these are these
opposite Ray's well let's see you've got
C B okay so that's going like this and a
B that's going like this but you can see
there they're overlapping similar to
these two rays but they're just on the
same line so again these are not
opposite raised letter C you can see
here's ray a B and here's Ray HC notice
they both have that same starting point
again which is called the end point but
they're not going at 180 degrees
opposite to one another so these are
also not opposite rays and a letter D
let me show you exactly what opposite
rays are so say for example you're
starting here and you're going this
direction and then you're starting here
and you're going this direction let's
just label this x y&z so ray Y Z okay
and Ray y ax okay like that these are
opposite rays now again notice how the
arrows are always going to the right
when you write the Ray but you can see
they're both starting at Y okay and then
this one's going towards Z and this
one's going towards X what I usually
tell students what I'm tutoring them is
that just think about you know you and
your friend you're talking and then your
friend has to go to class in that
direction and you have to go to class
the other direction
but you're at that same starting point
and you had opposite ways 180 degrees so
I hope this helps you understand what
opposite rays are a little bit better
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my other math videos on Mario's math
tutor and YouTube channel and I look
forward to seeing in the future videos
I'll talk to you soon